[Music]
it has been just over a year since Ghost
Recon wildlands released to what seemed
like little fanfare it came on the tail
end of a raucous first quarter including
the Renaissance of Resident Evil the
return of gorilla Studios and of course
the launch of nintendos next console
that's not to mention the massive new
Zelda that came with it toss in a
smattering of indie darlings and
successful triple-a releases and you
have a landmark quarter across numerous
genres it's no wonder the newest Ghost
Recon the next in a long line of Tom
Clancy shooters claims so little real
estate in the collective conversation
nevertheless wildlands actually sold
really well it outperforms zelda in the
u.s. netting more overall revenue in
their release month of March it may not
have dominated the spotlight like breath
of the wild did but it had a huge
following I compare these two titles
because they release four days apart but
also because they both feature
open-world structures sell those fantasy
trappings may clash with ghosts recons
military aesthetic but both stress
exploration as a pillar of their design
faced with a choice between these time
intensive games I chose zelda granting
me more time with my new Nintendo switch
and satisfying my thirst for a fresh
take on Hyrule but just recently news of
Ghost recons next major update complete
with Rainbow six siege cameos piqued my
interest
knowing Ubisoft's penchant for post
release support I jumped into wildlands
anticipating a host of changes and they
are definitely present but in a wider
sense I'm discovering a variety of
things I didn't fully appreciate a year
ago when I first played wildlands how
well the world facilitates stealth for
instance or how subtly it transitions
from one environment to the next or how
its parts coalesced to create one of my
favorite cooperative experiences since
left 4 dead 2 don't get me wrong there
are massive flaws here in fact for
everything I adore about wildlands I
seem to find one more I can't stand as
someone with a long history of playing
Tom Clancy titles and a longer history
of playing shooters this game has me
conflicted the way I see it wild lands
represents both the best and worst
aspects of Ubisoft's open-world games
and one year after Ghost Recon is
released both sides are all the more
pronounced
[Music]
[Music]
if you haven't played wildlands here's
the abbreviated plot for u.s. army
members drop into a bolivia overtaken by
the mexican drug cartel known as Santa
Blanca
if you speak basic Spanish then you know
how on the nose or even in the nose this
name is like can we get some legal coca
your mission is to take down El sueño
the head of Santa Blanca and any
underboss is standing in your way
all of this unfolds in a massive open
world much has been said about ubisoft's
and boxes from the historical
recreations of Assassin's Creed city to
the cascading mission structure of the
Far Cry franchise but wildlands version
of Bolivia is a fascinating marvel in
its own right civilians exist only as
window dressing targets to avoid as you
mow your way through the cartel villages
serve more as stages for firefights than
places I can actually imagine people
gathering there's also a general lack of
combat variety that increases the more
time you spend with a game but viewed as
a sandbox meant to encourage tactical
stealth wildlands is almost unparalleled
viewed from a distance the game most
closely resembles Metal Gear Solid 5 the
phantom pain the latter is the superior
game in most regards but there is a lot
to learn from Ghost Recon swirled when
clearing an enemy camp you not only have
to choose an angle of approach but also
how you'll escape in the aftermath you
can use your drone to scout a base
before sneaking in for close quarters
combat if there's a machine jamming your
drone you can perch on a nearby cliff
and Scout the base from above if you're
extracting a cartel lieutenant you can
plan your exfiltration route through the
surrounding marshes to a boat you left
idling upriver that will soon take you
to your hideout this all works so well
in these scenarios pop up so often
because of wildland strong sense of
geography the world slowly changes from
arid plateaus to mountainous farmland
snake-like canyons to vast flat salt
deserts there is also an impressive
sense of verticality as you descend
sloping coca field
to escape a cartel outpost high up on a
hill many of these thrills are amplified
in coop I can spot enemies for two of my
teammates directing them through the
alleyways in town squares below while
our forth number circles in a chopper
nearby ready to pick us up at a moment's
notice
other times we would split into teams of
two one to disable the power generator
the other to eliminate the cartel leader
before slipping away under cover of
darkness
the thing with wildlands is that despite
my adoration for many of its aspects
I recommend it with major caveats for
one wildlands is much better on higher
difficulties it makes the world feel
more dangerous encourages stealth and
evasion and turns the game from a power
fantasy into a survival scenario if
you're feeling particularly brave play
it on ghost mode which Institute's perma
death and resets all of your progress
each time you die lastly try to be
stealthy Ubisoft Paris designed wild
lands to allow for numerous approaches
and while that's great in theory the
game does not hold up in all-out combat
shooting can be clunky firefights become
monotonous and AI teammates
despite being vastly improved in the
months since the game's release aren't
always reliable companions I so strongly
prefer a stealthy approach in wild lands
that I wish you be soft had focused
solely on designing a stealth game it
feels as if half of the team wanted to
make a GTA clone allowing for hilarious
mishaps and vehicle based hijinks across
the map and to be clear these options
are present but they feel more like an
afterthought than an actual pillar of
design in many ways wildlands feels like
two separate parts rather than one
unified game and this dichotomy pervades
not only the gameplay but the narrative
as well on the one hand wildlands is a
cheesy action romp filled with cringy
dialogue and npc banter on the other
it's a lukewarm examination of the war
on drugs if you've seen clear and
present danger or the more recent
Sicario you'll probably find wildlands
to be lacking in the narrative
Department it attempts to tell a similar
story to these films but it stumbles by
pulling punches when it could hit hard
it's also missing a self-awareness that
makes a rock stars open worlds work so
well they find ways to rectify the
overall storyline with the frequent
chaos unfolding on screen now I don't
think every game about the war on drugs
needs to say the same thing or to align
with a certain worldview especially in
the case of wildlands it's a third
person shooter designed to be fun it is
designed to entertain what's frustrating
is that Ubisoft Paris so frequently
hints at compelling topics only to
backtrack immediately afterward listen
to this dialogue between Ghost Recon
squad members the Bolivian economy was a
wreck back then if people got into coke
just to survive here's one more instance
after I cleared out a pyro lucite mine
which the cartel used to refine the
ingredients to make cocaine of these
cases raised interesting questions can
you ever stop the drug trade are you
actually making things worse by being
here Ghost Recon protagonists are
dropped into a foreign country to follow
the orders of a revenge-seeking CIA
handler imagine if wild lands explored
that blind obedience these operatives
are doing their job yes but at what
point does that job cross the line in
one cutscene I recently saw and I
actually don't want to show here that
same CIA operative forces a cartel boss
to snort line after line of cocaine as a
form of torture she only allows him to
stop once he gives her the information
she's seeking when put up against
everything else you're doing in this
game and the hilarious situations you
often find yourself in it just felt a
little tone deaf in general I think
wildlands would be much better if it
allowed for player agency in the
narrative it often gives you freedom and
how you explore the map build your
character and clear enemy outposts so
why not extend that freedom into the
story as well ghost recounts boss fights
are probably the best example of this
inherent conflict after gaining enough
Intel in each of Bolivia's provinces you
have the chance to kill capture or frame
the local cartel boss the problem is you
don't get to choose you're forced into
specific scenarios that fly in the face
of the player choice you have
until that point for example I poured
almost all of my skill points into
stealth abilities improving my drones
recon powers and making my character
more silent overall this build served me
very well as I almost always opted for
stealth when I could but then I came
across a Foss flying a heavily armed
helicopter and could only complete the
mission by shooting him out of the sky
my stealth upgrades were all but useless
to be fair wildlands gave me access to
grenade launchers and light machineguns
in the planning phase that would have
made my job easier but at the same time
the game was telling me my choice to be
stealthy up until that point didn't mean
as much anymore
prior missions stress player choice but
this boss and many others took that all
away I just wish that agency made its
way into every corner of wildlands
framework what if you be soft designed a
full-fledged faction system throughout
the campaign one that lets you choose
between helping the rebels or the
state-run military what if you could
choose how to deal with each cartel
leader rather than following the orders
of an NPC across the map now I realize
this would spark numerous complications
for the developers and would be a much
more difficult project to make and not
every game needs to be Bioshock or spec
ops the line in the way it makes you
question your role as the player but
hear me out
wildlands is set in a part of the world
where the drug trade has played a large
part in shaping the culture and economy
for decades the subject is ripe for
exploration and it's not one that you
can half-ass but in wild lands Ubisoft
does exactly that there's a gaping chasm
between the complex stage wild land sets
and the things it actually makes you do
I don't envy the team of writers that
has to contextualize any open-world
story telling your own plot while
accounting for player freedom is a
massive challenge but recent titles such
as The Legend of Zelda breath of a wild
and horizons euro Don have shown that it
can be done they've shown that the
open-world structure can serve to
enhance the narrative not clash with it
in returning to Ghost Recon wildlands I
found a game that exemplifies my take on
Ubisoft's open-world portfolio a craft
on display is unparalleled in its sense
of place but there is still a huge hole
where the narrative should be games such
as Far Cry 5 and Assassin's Creed
origins have crept a little closer to
more meaningful open worlds
but the publisher still hasn't come
close to its full potential
if you be soft could just take that
extra step into complicated territory it
could make timeless pieces of
entertainment games that are fun and
nuanced games that give us more to talk
about as the months roll by I don't
think it's a fluke that wildlands came
and went last year without much buzz it
released on the tail end of a crowded
first quarter but it also had an
identity problem and it still does it
feels torn between an all-out romp
through a lukewarm world and a thrilling
stealth game with an amazing sense of
place I only wish you be soft had
carried through on its promise of player
choice I wish the team had stuck to a
more refined vision than trying to
appeal to every single player there is a
strong intricate skeleton of a game here
it just needs a heart
[Music]